wendy williams talk show will be without
her for at least another month
[Applause]
the tv personality is not returning to
daytime tv as she faces ongoing health
issues she's missed out on all of her
13th season so far the show returned in
october with guest hosts after delaying
its premiere by nearly a month as wendy
dealt with health issues behind the
scenes on wednesday the show announced
substitute hosts will continue to step
in for wendy throughout the month of
november the new lineup includes
comedians michael rappaport and bill
bellamy
and even familiar daytime faces jerry
springer and steve wilkos isn't that
fabulous the wendy williams show kicked
off its premiere month with a special
hot topics table led by comic michael yo
we are so happy to be here
how are you doing
then leah remini fronted a week of shows
so it is time for ask leah okay and
michelle followed by whitney cummings
benton will do uh
wendy's iconic phrase with me on three
you guys do it with us one two three how
are you doing
while the stars fill in wendy is said to
be focusing on her health in a statement
shared to the show's instagram account
last month wendy's team said the host
continues to be under a doctor's care
and is experiencing serious
complications due to graves disease and
her thyroid condition my thyroid my
hyperthyroid is attached also to
graves disease
graves disease
squeezes the muscles behind your
eyeballs the statement added that she'll
need more time to recover before
returning to live tv but as soon as
she's ready she'll be back in her
treasured purple chair we've got a lot
to talk about now there is no denying
that during this time fans are missing
hearing wendy's iconic how you doing
directly from her
i'm doing okay let's get started when et
spoke with the host in 2020 the tv
personality opened up about how she won
over her audience just by being herself
you know in the very beginning uh
you know if you're a star and you come
to new york and you want to be on talk
shows you were on other talk shows the
more established ones with your friends
who've been there for years and you'd be
like wendy okay no we're not going over
there you know or isn't she the one with
the big mouth isn't she the one who says
this or that or the third
and so then
there were people who wanted me to calm
down wendy if you want guests you got to
calm down
i'm like i don't know how to calm down
what am i saying that's so bad
and um
then
we started making hot topics longer and
people loved it and then we started
using up more programming time for that
hour with ask wendy and they became
juicier like about threesomes and stuff
and then um eye candy became more eye
candy
and and it just and before you know it
the whole show is no celebrity guest
and i i'll be honest with you i love my
celebrity friends i really do but
it feels really good to know that me
and my staff and crew have built
a sustainable talk show
with no celebrities at all
[Music]